[Music]
hi my name is jackal pouch and I'm a
software engineer to Sigma hi I'm Sam
Tsui wasana product management director
in G CP and I work on security topics
mmm and we're here to present to Sigma
implementing FinTech security in the
cloud so to begin with what is 2 Sigma
we're a technology driven investment
manager that uses data science to derive
insights that forecast the future and
cover value in the markets worldwide and
we do so using technologies like AI and
ml in a lot and I repeat a lot of
distributed computing for that we have
so for this for this for this topic what
we want to emphasize is the fact that we
have very very high value IP that is
probably one of the more important
points for us because unlike a lot of
companies unlike maybe some of you guys
if we have a breach it's not just a
little problem it's a big problem
because if anyone else has our IP or we
don't have our IP we can't exactly go
forward right so what is our problem in
that sense then so we want to strike the
right balance between security and
access so on one hand we want a secure
environment or we can protect ourselves
from external and internal threats but
at the same time we don't want to block
our developers or modelers our
stakeholders in general from accessing
that data and who are those stakeholders
we actually have quite a large number of
them we have our internal users which
are the people inside the Sigma that
process a lot of data and run models on
them and this is internal data and on
the converse side of that we have our
external users which also process a
large amount of data but in this case
it's external data to the Sigma and
under them we have these modelers that
take that data and create models and
implement them and over that we also
have this community which are you know
people that use our products that aren't
directly connected to us for instance we
have this game called halite which is
art of artificial artificial
intelligence challenge that has
thousands and thousands of users from
across the globe running arbitrary code
and we have them as stakeholders as well
and under all of that we have our
internal developers that build the tools
for all of these people to use and of
course we also have our security team
that also want to build secure tools on
top of the cloud and that want to keep
that cloud protected using lease
privilege so what are we gonna do today
today we're going to talk to you step by
step how to build your own security on
GCP that somewhat mimics that what we
have a similar a simulacrum of what we
have and we're gonna start from scratch
and build it slowly and build it easily
in a very abstract and
easy-to-understand way such that you can
benefit from our hindsight in what way
well as we build things from scratch we
had our problems and we followed some
paths that really led nowhere and we had
to go back and we had to redo and that
took time but right now we're gonna walk
you through the exact path in the right
way so you can do it the right way the
first time and I also want to emphasize
again this isn't exactly how it looks
like internally to us but it's close
enough that it can be abstracted to all
of you and so to start with or to end
with this is what you're going to have
when all is well and done of course
don't be scared by that we're gonna walk
you step by step from the beginning how
to get to this complex image right now
and Sam's gonna take over and talk you
through that thank you jack so as Jack
said you saw the complex diagram just
before this you're gonna start from
scratch and build layer by layer as to
get there in each point you will have an
understanding of why we did that and you
can follow that is a kind of a high
level road map you could follow each
level we'll talk about what threats we
were considering and you might follow
the same thing when setting up an
environment from scratch so here is
something where there is nothing
you just become Stu Sigma has just come
on to GCP they're super admins have just
signed up so obviously need some God a
kind of admin to set things up and have
set up an organization nothing's been
set up yet and on the side obviously
they have their existing on-prem data
center and that has some kind of local
computing already their servers have
existed and very importantly it has the
root of all their identity which is
Active Directory which is where all
their employees and perhaps contractors
and so on are so the very first step
basically is to connect up the
identities from their Active Directory
on to the Google cloud setup so what
here you're doing is to ensure that in
Google cloud platform when you're
writing an IM rule every developer every
Jo every Alice is available with the
group settings and to do that the to
Sigma use something which we call a tool
which is available called GCD SS Google
cloud directory sync it works with
Active Directory and synchronizes all
your user and group information on to
the Google cloud and going a step
further at this point you could actually
if you were doing this you could say
well that's great now I would like to
use Google as a primary login to my
system so in other words you go to the
Google login page your developer logs in
and now they're ready to set up a VM or
whatever it might be but you have
another choice and that's the choice
which to sigmah made to Sigma was using
an Active Directory as their SSO and
they chose to stick with activity as SSO
for reasons which Jacque will come back
later in their use case it was important
and that again is possible to set up you
have the Google login system can run
headless so to speak and instead
Confederate on to Active Directory which
setup with the sam'l and so the user
experience would be for a developer you
see the familiar Active Directory web
login and then you actually are now
logged into Google and you can be ready
to set up resources now setting up
resources let's talk about what that is
so obviously the only reason you have
you're on the cloud is to set them to
have computing and data and so on so
here basically there are three canonical
examples we have in this abstract
diagram and this is actually very much
applied to the obviously what to Sigma
really did they have a bunch of Linux
VMs and the Linux VM is actually
embodied the custom IP which Jacque was
talking about they might be doing some
custom modeling a very high value IP and
they running models and so forth there's
an app engine application and the App
Engine application is the control for
this in other words if I'm a developer
an external model or one of the user
types he talked about you would see a
web interface you would do various
things in it and in the back you'd be
running the models on these Linux VMs
and of course data stored in cloud
storage
so the first step again we are doing
this systematically so you'd say create
these resources at this point if you
haven't yet set up set them up to be
locked down securely and what's the
first step to be taken what it to Sigma
do is lock them down the very first step
is obviously to use I am so the all
security really as you can and I think
it's a fair thing to say is about
controlling who can access what and the
first step is to say that app engine
setup can only be manipulated by our
DevOps group and similarly something
similar for the Linux VMs maybe some
other group but maybe it's DevOps and
similarly further cloud storage access
policy so we set these up what that
means is that obviously locking down in
a in a very big way you can't for
example I could be logged in a sub gmail
account and I can't access it anymore
and however at this point I'll just make
a point that the somebody the DevOps
group can maintain that happens you know
change the settings I am settings or
whatever it might be or use ap as
against App Engine they could do it from
the office but I could do it from
anywhere and just hold that thought in
your mind so at this point we have
locked down these resources with basic I
so I'll give it back to Jack to tell us
what we've done so far so what did we do
we set up TCP using our super admin
account
we sync their user identities using ad
and now we can really add we have that
direct connectivity there and we set up
our first resources we now have EMS we
have buckets and we have the raw access
control rules for them but not
everything is perfect right now now we
have some concerns we set everything up
using the super admin and he has very
very large powers so how could you make
sure that that can't be compromised that
a third party can't gain access to that
and do evil things or if you know the
soup rattling can't do something by
mistake
we do have all those resources and they
are accessible by two sigma but they're
also accessible outside to Sigma and
that isn't necessarily something we want
we want something that our developers
can can use but not elsewhere and again
all resources now can be accessed
everywhere we don't really have any
block any firewall anything permitting
prohibiting them from using it elsewhere
and finally our developers want to use
Kerberos they want to sign into things
directly using it and we currently don't
really have a way to sync that through
our ad so Sam will tell us how to
resolve those issues so the first point
shock bid was the super admin privilege
is pretty scary because this is like a
guard privilege and you always need that
in the you setting up your cloud you're
always going to have some foundational
accounts and a set of you want to reduce
it to as few as possible but you're
still going to have something and that's
not going to be necessarily on your SSO
because this is the essentially
bootstrap account so how can we make it
more secure so the big concern you have
and with account security is phishing
and so if you have of course you might
put a password obviously as a password
you might put an OTP on this
that's very good progress but for
something which could potentially shut
down in production systems or whatever
that's the kind of privileges this admin
as we want to lock down further and what
to Sigma has done is it used an MFA
product called a security key and shut
down and lock down the sessions to be
very short and let me tell you a little
bit more about security key
so as I said phishing is the number one
login attack however sophisticated user
might be there typically is a very
crafted way where when they're not
paying attention you can associate try
and fish them for their login
credentials and any what's called a
better credential think anything which
you can type somewhere you can be typing
in the wrong place so there obviously
applies to passwords applies to OTPs now
we're not trying to sell our teepees
down the river
Oh teepees are a huge step up but for
the what's at stake here we have to go
further and what the security key gives
you is essentially a second factor
specifically designed to defeat phishing
now defeats a strong word nothing is
perfect but it inherently has this
design and so how does that work you do
use eclipse stalk about user experience
first we'll security key or super admin
you type in login password you stick a
key in the USB port and press a button
what's happening behind the covers on
the server side when it verifies the
second factor or two things firstly each
of these Keys the crypto key it has a
private key tied only to the account so
of course it verifies it a is a
signature from the from this particular
the account which is is a key which is
attached to this account secondly the
signature area what is within the signed
bondrée also has what the URL that the
browser is seeing in the in actually
where you're type over there basically
the e TLD that's a pretty key thing
effectively the server can see where
where did you type in the login and
password did you type it at google.com
or fake google.com and in effect that is
what prevents the phishing angle and
such a very significant upgrade to
security and so the foundational super
admin logins are logged locked down this
way and you also get one really nice
bonus from this and it's it's an
oriented bonus from the key but
basically now you can have multiply
multi-party off the idea is if you can
share your password with one party and
you can share the key with an other
party suddenly you can you can make sure
that any time someone logs into that
account in each to have both of those
people and kind of like you know in
those old movies where two people had to
turn the key to launch the launches yeah
yeah in fact that's a very interesting
use which to sigmah made which typically
you might say that's great and all this
add super admin make it even more secure
I don't want just a Jorah Alice to have
power do this they might go rogue on me
or they might make a mistake they've
effectively used this feature to
separate out the privileges so Joe's got
the password and this has got the key
and as a minor point you can actually
have multiple keys to an account so you
can have Alice and Jane and Bob perhaps
if you if you so choose so any two of
them kind of thing so going back to what
Jack had said he said well there are
various things wrong which I want to
improve one thing was locking down the
admin account the next thing which she
pointed out was initially we set up the
for example an app engine to be accessed
only by DevOps but you can also have the
App Engine instance to be accessed or
controlled by any identity in Google
that's a feature not a bug for example
you in your case you might say we want
this contractor or that company which we
have a deal with to be able to control
our resources however in their case they
want to have a lock down they want to
ensure that these resources cannot be
even accidentally have allowed access to
anybody other than identity from to
Sigma and so here again
they enable something which what was
called an org wide policy so you got
your organization the container in which
all your resources live and you can put
an organizer which essentially says in
plain English allow only two Sigma
entities to be having control on these
and so what that really does is
basically prevent any kind of
inadvertent mistakes of example someone
in a project a junior engineer project
project somebody he or she might have a
bright idea we just share some data
directly with an external contractor
with all good intention but this is
essentially prevents that
so there are other org wide policies to
which to Sigma chose to use and again
this might work are very useful for you
also and in their case for example they
set up a policy where a VM image which
is used in one project cannot be shared
to another project and Jack maybe you
can tell us a little bit about the
motivation here so this this is an issue
for which we were pioneers in we were we
found out firsthand that Google had
added a specific feature that allowed
you to move images from within projects
which is actually quite a useful feature
because in a lot of cases you do want to
do that for us however that's an
exfiltration vector that means that we
can have a very lockdown project and the
non lockdown project within the same org
and suddenly we can copy that image that
has all our private IP to the other
project and then take everything out and
we came to Google with that problem and
we said you know we don't necessarily
want that and Google came around and
made us this specific org to help us to
specifically block that which is a great
boon to Google's yeah so the like Jack
said in their case they have multiple
stake I know stakeholders end-users and
there may be different policies relevant
to each and this prevents the
information sharing at the very image
level so going on to one more again it
is the theme here being or wide control
to set them up at organization level one
of the control this they chose to set up
is that they allow no serial port access
to VMs now serial port access to V Eames
again is a feature it might be in your
case you might want to allow that but in
the case I did not and just to recap you
bring up a VM if it's on the network you
can SSH to it but then there might be
some network configuration it might not
be accessible the serial port is the sub
network you're accessing it in quotes
directly and that's what we allow but in
their case they chose not to allow that
and Jack maybe you can tell us what
drove that sure so again that access is
unrestricted it is useful you have if
you have a network if you have a machine
that's breaking and you can't get
through the network and you configured
something wrong somewhere and you really
have to get to that VM this is the way
to do it and it's it's useful but again
for us that's an exfiltration vector I
mean somebody can forego all of the
network
and just go directly into your project
into your VM and take everything out as
long as they know the password which I'm
sure malicious people can get so we
wanted to block that so let's take a
little bit of a stock of where we are so
we have a set up an integrated set of
policies every one of those yellow lines
that you see it represents basically
policy which we you saw us setting up so
at the App Engine instance the compute
engine instance is the cloud storage we
set up policies the group level as you
remember the super admins are locked
down so that they can only have a
phishing resistant login and with short
sessions the admin uses identity
effectively they are delegated down to
Mac to directly that's the policy and
the box around to Sigma organization if
you remember we said policies saying
that you can't share any resources from
outside you can't copy images you can't
lock down serial port and so forth so
let's take some stock here and I'll give
that back to Jack now so we know lock
down our super admin login so Brad means
now don't have godlike powers we know it
didn't allow resources to be shared
outside to Sigma identities so people
outside to Sigma really can't access
anything yet but we still haven't solved
everything
resources can Silvie access from
anywhere and we still don't have our
much-desired
Kerberos for our deaths and sentence
gonna walk us through how we get that so
a network layer control as all of us
know we want multiple layers of access
controls and one conservative and
obvious access control mechanisms to put
a network boundary around a set of
resources and make sure they cannot be
accessed from anywhere but there so
that's called a V PC and in this slide
we show the first step of a V PC which
is around the Linux VMs and there it's
what you would it's a classic network
construct you have a bunch of the Linux
machines and you put a basically a
firewall around them and they cannot
open a TCP connection or SSH or whatever
SCP out from the boundary and similarly
their private IP s they can't be
accessed on
outside that's interesting but we want
to bring that notion of VPC not just to
these just a translation of the physical
past but also to these virtual
constructs or these cloud constructs
which is the app engine and a cloud
storage and how do we do that so what is
a mechanism for doing so and so
essentially we want to say these things
cannot be access from the outside so
there again as you can imagine it's in
the cloud everything is policy in
conflict driven and on the VPC you set a
resource policy to do precisely that so
in effect you are here there is the
plain English notion is you cannot
access data from the outside from the
containing VPC or from out of the
containing VPC and what it really means
is that that app engine instance the
cloud service instance now their
management or access to the api's if you
remember before they were locked down to
the DevOps group or whatever the DevOps
group can no longer do it from anywhere
on the internet they can only do it if
their source IP or dec with their within
the private network so in effect
bringing these abstractions which
google's providing you also within the
notion of a network boundary so having
said that the next step we do is this
VPC obviously is like what you would
expect it is a it is a private network
and you connect it up here to your
on-prem and what to Sigma chose to do is
there are multiple options you can use
either a site-to-site VPN or something
called a private interconnect and they
chose to use a private interconnection
that gives them some amazing speeds is
60 cubic gigabit connection so in this
context we're talking about a security
but it's also really really fast so the
connection once you connect it up to
your on-premise your V PC which is on
the cloud that brings us to a solution
for the fourth problem with shark talked
about which is basically that the
developers were used before when on Prem
if you see the local compute on the in
on Prem they were used to getting a
Kerberos ticket from Active Directory
and logging into their Linux machines on
Prem
the exact same thing basically on
virtual machines which are now on cloud
and this when you hack hook up the
network this way you have the private
connectivity and the Cobras ticket now
can travel over the network and so you
can get Kerberos access to the VMS and
so that basically gets us to where the
list of questions we have now gives us
back to Jack here so as as we talked
about before we had already solved 1 & 2
so unto 3 & 4 we now have the V PC so
now data can't be easily you know
exfiltrated from that and we enabled
Kerberos when our developers can just
sign into things directly without all
that hassle but we're still not 100%
there yet so a bad insider can to copy
the data out of the network we locked it
down right but we only did it directly
what if someone indirectly takes the
data copies it to another GCP resource
and takes it out from that open GCP
resource like a personal bucket so
buckets of encryption by default which
is good but we have compliance issues
and we need to manage the keys so we can
give good compliance visibility and
right now no resources can be accessed
from outside the PPC but sometimes you
want to give access we want people from
the internet to have access to some of
our data so how can we do that securely
in a way that doesn't break what we have
right now and Sam's gonna talk about
that thanks jack so the first problem
which Jack talked about was do we set up
a VPC boundary and though it was the
case that that App Engine instance now
cannot be accessed by Joe and DevOps
other unless join dev offices within the
VP C networks or this week they still a
problem which is that if Joe goes rogue
in principle Joe could or given Joe by
making a inadvertent mistake could set
up instance of a personal bucket and
could make a copy from the data which is
inside the V PC to the personal bucket
in essence we don't have an outbound we
at that point at this point of the build
we don't have an outbound for
also to speak which prevents you to add
from accessing any resource within GCP
that are GCP resource which is not
within your VPC so this precisely now
what we are as a policy so we add a
policy saying no GCP resources outside
my VPC can be accessed from inside the
vp c so you can think of example all
Claude buckets and GCP now broken into
two sets one is the sets which are
within your V PC as you've designated
and one is everything else it doesn't
matter who owns them it could be your
organization or somebody else now those
even though the API endpoint for
obviously cloud storage is accessible
you cannot access those particular
resources and so this cuts out this huge
exfiltration vector and you can think of
this as then a completion step where
you're truly bringing just your cloud
resources within your network boundary
and the B this is feature in case you're
looking for it it's called VPC service
control and there's something which you
might want to enable in your setup also
the next point which Jacque talked about
was that if you use our storage
offerings by default all data is
encrypted at rest and we manage the keys
it Google manages the keys but for
visibility of a compliance in your case
you might say that I want that key
management and luckily Google premier
provides a feature for that with the
cloud key Manek kms feature and so what
happens is that you set up an instance
of cloud kms and in this case was to
Sigma to manage their kms keys and again
is policy driven you effectively in
essence you are setting the cloud
storage instances to use keys that
you're managing and it's a policy so
once again it's software driven config
driven and so at this point we have
solved a problem of the visibility of
our control over the keys which are key
management which Jacque was
looking for and that brings us to the
next point with Jacques name so the only
reason you build systems are for access
and in the end some subset of users you
want them to have convenient access
ideally from anywhere and safely and so
here the end users in their setup could
be employees could be those external
modelers and other here Jacques Torres
over six classes of users how do we
enable you don't want to bring them all
inside your production network obviously
for access you want to keep them outside
but give them safe access to what you
want to publish and that's precisely
what the ia P allows so I a P stands for
identity of a proxy so it is essentially
a reverse proxy front end which is
internet facing for your back-end
application if you remember we talked
about his back-end app engine
application and as I said that's a web
application written by two sigma to
essentially provide a unified front end
to all the complex processing happening
at the back model running and so on how
do you take that application and publish
it to the Internet in a safe fashion
that's precisely what I ap does so in
this case you see this name to Sigma
comm this they published an application
to Sigma R consequently to the Internet
when you come to through Sigma dot com
as a user from the internet the backend
application are hitting really is back
in App Engine application however this
is a bit more to that you can
essentially write what 2 Sigma has done
is used if the I am features of IP you
can write in policies as to who can
access the application so in this case
we just made up this example maybe this
to Sigma or Chrome application can
access be accessed only by the
contractors group just say so and what
happens is that at every HTTP request
the actual user logged in is validated
by AP and if the policy allows it sends
the hit to the backend if not since you
have
gives you you know polite page saying
sorry you're not allowed access to this
resource the nice thing about this is
that the back end App Engine application
was written with no particular access
controls baked into it because you you
never know tomorrow you might want some
other group to access it so now your
infrastructure which is enables you to
essentially add these access controls
right in the front end and provide you
just the limited access that you want so
let me get back to Jack to see where we
are now in this journey so right now we
we made sure that insiders can't me
misuse the resources to indirectly take
that out manage the encryption keys to
make sure all the storage is compliant
and visible all the the keys are
invisible and we publish end-user
applications safely to the internet so
people can now use our services outside
but of course we do have one last issue
and as my colleague Nakia van itís
always quotes if if you feel that you're
100% secure and you haven't been broken
into you likely have been broken into
and you just don't know about it so no
security is a hundred percent perfect
and for the cases where it actually does
go wrong because things do go wrong we
need to be able to figure out what went
wrong check on it and fix it later so
for that we need status and forensics
and for that we have a number of tools
initially we have stackdriver which
gives us the logs that tells us who did
what when not why but if what and when
we have CSEC which gives us a console
that tells us the consolidated status of
everything that we have in our
organization and finally we have googles
for SETI with the open source tool for
SETI to automate the monitoring and the
setting up of policies and I guess one
thing I should mention for those who
don't know is claw CSEC stands for cloud
security command center it's essentially
intended to be a central console where
you get visibility into all your
security monitoring and for city set of
open source tools that we
Alfred looking for city at all
specifically so you can automate setting
up and monitoring of policies and in GCP
and action beyond actually and finally
we come back to our finalized picture of
what you should have if you want a
secure environment with all the features
that Google has so you're not you so we
finally got to that level that we want
we want secure inside outside and we
have not built any walls for our
developers as the quote often say it
says bold bold guardrails not walls so
everything is usable everything is
secure and we did it simply step by step
so you guys can follow it and to sum it
up to Sigma we're a fin tech company
with extremely high value IP like many
of you might have and as I said we need
to lock everything down but made make
access easy and we need a hybrid
solution that spends both cloud and
on-premise in GCP we get a control to do
so securely easily and still use a lot
of features and we because of them were
able to easily stitch all of that
together to exact our needs so Sam will
tell us how where we can go next yes so
if you saw the core principle in what we
were doing which is really applies to
cloud really is that as I said access
controlling access is what we're
security is all about and so we would at
every point we were using access
controls I did identity driven access
controls to say who can access what so
here and we say who it was people things
so this this this group of people can
access this application published out of
the Internet this group of people can
add it can set this app engine instance
but only if they're in this in this
context for example from when they've it
in the V PC and so forth the next step
essentially is to but however at this
stage of the conversation when Linux VM
called another Linux VM basically it was
a TCP connection may be it may call some
API but that was not a named thing at at
this point
and so the
- Sigma is we are having conversations
is to take the notion of identity driven
access not just for human beings but is
the services themselves which is or if
you agree I'm sure you've been listening
the keynotes when we talk about sto and
RPG that's what it's about so now every
service actually has a name and
basically any and you can say set
policies use a platform allows you to do
where before you could say only Jo can
access the API and now you can say which
services can access what other service
and so everything baguettes publishes
API is and you essentially have inter
service controls on a service and data
driven basis and so that's the next
stage so you can just think of kicking
the notion of security controls further
and further up the stack not that the
lower layers become obviated by any
means the network layers are extremely
important but they were basically once
you put in there they're sort of from I
can use the word fairly crude at meaning
because they don't have the higher-level
concepts and then you basically now
focus your security setup more at the
identity layers for both individuals and
for services and that's where the
conversations going with - Sigma at
least you and happy G and they have been
a partner for us actually in driving
many of the controls that we put in and
we look forward to their feedback
when the same thing and similarly from
all of you please join us in this
journey use what you've got and then set
up all the controls that you haven't
tell us what's missing and so help us
drive it where it's complete from your
perspective there may be other controls
which were not relevant to them which
you might need which we are not aware of
let's talk about that and again I can't
emphasize that enough
always always work with Google because
no matter where you go what you do
anywhere nothing will be a hundred
percent what you need but working with
where you can get it to that hundred
percent of what you need and they will
help and they're actually very very
helpful from am's - PMS to dance -
everyone at Google they really really
help you drive to where your solution
needs to go thank you thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]